welcome back to Rich Eisen show here on
this radio station as well as
youtube.com slash Rich Eisen show
management telling me you got to put
your show on YouTube why are you out on
YouTube you got to do it on YouTube just
like the Pat McAfee show that's live
every single day Friday from 10 to noon
Eastern Time and then its podcast app at
McAfee Show 2.0 Pat McAfee back here on
the show you're on YouTube look at us
Pat look at us took chatting in many
different ways now look at us hey it's
great to be in the future here isn't it
I mean you have been a guy that has set
the tone in this industry for a long
time and now you were setting the tone
for the next generation of broadcasters
who want to create their own shows well
on YouTube not worry about J keepers
telling you what's good and what isn't
good I love what you're doing I'm
excited to continue to watch you every
single day brother you're the best I
enjoyed being on your show the other day
where me and you and Ryan leaf on the
couch and you know how about leaf
telling that story about what DD say
that somebody reached out to him about
about the Chargers didn't you say that
somebody reached out to him about or his
dad about the Chargers before they drove
RG he said Archie Manning right oh yeah
Archie Manning reached out to his dad
about how did the Chargers organization
treat your boy and I think Ryan Leaf he
has owned everything that he has done
wrong in his life actually with the
Chargers he's owned it and I think his
dad thought there wasn't enough support
potentially at the time from the
Chargers organization and I think he
told that to Archie and then when he
spilled that information to us we were
both like wait a minute we looked at
each other we shot this look Chris this
was amazing Ryan Leaf telling the story
that when Eli was going through whether
or not to be drafted by the Chargers
okay Archie Manning called his dad Ryan
Leafs dad to kick the tires on and said
hey how's San Diego how did San Diego
treat your son Wow
and lo and behold Eli's a giant social
media that was happen now
right which people were alluding to
potentially happening with social media
that would be the biggest thing on earth
and it was it was covered obviously but
that conversation with Riley's
for March he could have been a little
bit of a part of that that's that would
be a massive little piece to the link if
that was happening in today's world at
McAfee here on the Rich Eisen show also
on youtube.com slash Rich Eisen show pat
welcoming us to the youtube world as his
show is on every single day check out
his channel right here on youtube as
well as any of the radio stations that
might be near you hey did you hear the
news out of New York the New York Post
reporting that ESPN is making a play for
Peyton Manning to join Al Michaels in
the booth did you hear about that yeah
we just retweeted Andrew Marshawn from
the post he tweeted this morning a
little teaser that he had big news
coming this afternoon and a column and
then in a series of tweets he kind of
unloaded that information you got to
think Mike Tirico is still on the NBC
Sports Officer my boys and I were
talking about it that is a potential
move that would be insane but also al
Michaels and Peyton Manning in a booth
together would be something I would want
to listen to and watch on a regular
basis and as you move to recoil up with
Collinsworth it seems like a win-win but
boy that is some high level conversation
that has to happen between networks to
kind of do that exchange I would assume
the money especially what do you see
what Tony Romo's making I mean that's a
big money move I'd assume and I love how
Michaels I hope he calls games forever
and hearing him with panning or with man
it would be awesome do you think Peyton
want Peyton wants to do it right but
only with the right person essentially
and obviously Peyton and I are not in
constant contact but I would assume that
they might have asked Dayton who are
some people you wouldn't mind working
with or that you Revere and he probably
said well I like how Michaels and I
don't even know if Peyton was saying
that is that would be the only person he
works with but I'm assuming he said it
right so now he s Ben's like we tried
dating before he said no people say it's
because he doesn't want to criticize you
I and stuff like that that's out the
window now what if we get a guy that he
likes get him in there
and I think the world would be excited
to hear Peyton every single Monday night
Pat McAfee here in the Rich Eisen show
so supposedly the collective bargaining
agreement has been hashed out between
the lawyers the final language of the
NFL and the NFL PA and have sent it on
to the players writ large the whole
group of players in the NFL
you were in the league the last time
this went around howl a 430 page
document land in the inbox of players
what do you got for me on how's that
gonna how's that gonna hit I was talking
that I was talking to Kyle Rudolph this
morning on my show and I obviously asked
him if he pushed off the answer saying
what do you say What did he say first
let's take one at a time you already say
to that he said I did not push off at
all my arm was that at full like
basically yet stiff so there's no push
off at all he just was keeping him away
and kind of do where he was at he didn't
push him at all I was like well it kind
of looks very similar to what happened
with George Kittel in the Super Bowl and
that was caller it was and he was like
nope that's gonna me they reviewed it
and everything so Kyle went to bat for
his move and just saying that he didn't
push off anything okay respect great
catch playoffs win again look Pat if
somebody's chest is gonna get in the way
of his hand and you know it's not his
fault right
you know how you suck the catch whenever
somebody's covered yes please I
understand how to get him off you right
it makes sense but Kyle Rudolph
obviously great personality good speaker
and also Notre Dame educated yes so this
is a guy who pretty difficult school
from what I've been told I was never
accepted to Notre Dame but from what
I've heard it's a little bit difficult
in the academic world and I told him so
what the hell are you gonna do with 450
Pete or whatever it is 430 pages like
are you gonna read that it was like well
I'm gonna dive into it today I'm like if
I was in the league right now there is
zero chance that I would read that but I
should that is something that every
player should read but there's no way
it's going to happen and when that means
is somebody's gonna place a vote and
then somebody's going to ask them why
they're gonna say no and it's going to
cause this entire conversation but
they're giving him a week and I just
don't see how anybody's gonna get that
done yeah let alone it that was a great
story or something like that 430 pages
that's more pages than I've ever read in
my life we were talking earlier like
when was the last time any of us read
something that was 430 pages long let
alone that there's fine print and and
formulas and stuff like that so how is
this gonna go down do you think what do
you think
that you're an idea and there's also the
legalities talk and a lot in percentages
of revenue sharing right I mean it's
just it's absolute insanity so what's
gonna happen is you're gonna get guys
that are meet in groups maybe they take
turns
they each read apart and kind of
summarize it or you can get guys that
listen to other people and it's it's
gonna be a very interesting thing
because there are two very different
views on this thing in the NFL I had
Nate solder on my show the other day
offensive tackle now for the Giants
formerly of the Patriots he likes it
round he likes it right he loves it
right he liked he said obviously there's
some drawbacks because in negotiations
that happens but he likes it and then
you hear the likes of marquees bouncing
you he does not like it I mean it's just
very it is very interesting to see how
this all plays out and they got a week
to vote on it and I think if you're a
fan and if you're somebody that covers
it it's like all right a lot about to
happen here in our football world
excited to see how it because it 17
games rich not only do we get more
football yeah we get more playoffs but
what happens with all the records pre
the 17 games I mean there's just there's
a lot of stuff to be unfolded here at
McAfee right here on the Rich Eisen show
how did the news that Dion was talking
about on Sunday on NFL Network during
our combine coverage that you just not
it's not news but I mean it's now
becoming news just the idea that Brady
might wind up a forty nine or how that
won't hit you that's a real conversation
that's happening right now in 2020 right
we are potentially thinking about the
greatest quarterback of all time going
to his hometown team for what two to
three years right in that hometown team
trading back to the genius that is Bill
Belichick his project is baby the guy
that he allegedly wanted all along I
mean it feels like a win-win for both
sides but John Lynch just said last week
that he's committed to Jimmy G is
nowhere near its ceiling and all that
and I understand in sports there's a lot
of lying about stuff but man I think the
49ers probably won a Super Bowl next
year if they gets on Brady and the
Patriots especially if Antonio Browns
people aren't lying about Tom Brady and
Antonio Brown being in contact with each
other and bringing him along because if
you lose Emmanuel Sanders you get in
Tonio Brown in there
and the Patriots Josh McDaniels get the
guy back in his team that already knows
it you get a guy who's already a proven
winner and the Patriots are gonna be
good for another 20 years
I mean it's just it's it seems like that
could potentially happen but in the end
of the day I feel like there's a lot of
smoke going on so let's just say it does
this is real right and the agent
represents both Brady and and Garoppolo
dong-yi do you do you as the client just
come straight through the front door and
say this is gonna be a tough one for you
or you just say it and just you know say
make it happen how do you do that you're
tough no if you're the Tom Brady in
you're like hey you know I know we went
down this road before but I want to do
it again but this time I want his job
not get him out I mean how do you lay
that one out to your representative
right I mean that just all right so we
this is what I'm thinking you know how
there is all that conversation about me
getting shipped out of town and Jimmy G
getting a starting job and all that
stuff and we agreed to send him to San
Francisco instead of me well now I want
to do the same exact thing but send his
ass to New England and that contradicts
Tom Brady right now though okay I
honestly I think he's about fed up with
the amount of talk about it yeah he also
he he fans the flame on a regular
occasion and it's just like there's
non-stop conversation about this until
wherever he goes he goes and then the
conversations gonna be like well how did
we get here what happened to this room
it's just this is so awesome for the NFL
I hope it happens every single on that's
right no doubt a few minutes left with
Pat McAfee here on the Rich Eisen show
when I saw you and I was on your show
last Friday in Indianapolis you said you
had just accepted an invitation from the
New Orleans pelicans to go to New
Orleans and introduce the team against
the Los Angeles Lakers in front of
everybody in the Smoothie King you
crushed it Pat you went out you
absolutely crushed it for my viewing
audience here on YouTube and listening
audience can you walk us through how
that started and and the approach you
took to introducing the New Orleans
pelicans in Zion Williamson please well
well first of all thank you for that you
all knew you were there I think for the
groundwork of that whole thing just sort
of come to fruition you kind of got to
see how this and I don't want to call it
in office but there's this area that we
send our time in every single day kind
of works and idea gets thrown out and
then we kind of put all right should we
do this should go do this let's go try
to kill it make a vlog about it and see
how it goes so I was happy you were
there because obviously you're a legend
in the building and you're the one that
told me mate maybe do a long Zion that's
right that of a long William Wright and
you know what i if you watched by the
way I tried to hang that Zion as long as
that marks but I think it a lot of
vitamins but I well you know because
again I I knew that you were gonna
introduce Zion that's the whole reason
why you were going is you had a problem
with the way that the pelicans were
doing it and then there essentially said
if you don't like the way it's done how
about you give it a whirl right and then
you went down and did it that's
essentially how it went down yeah the
opening night of Zion it was a Wednesday
night on ESPN o'clock I mean everybody
was looking forward to watching the game
and everybody was watching strictly for
Zion and then they cut back through his
intros his first time getting introduced
as a starter in the NBA and I thought
they introduced him second and I was
like second like this dude is the future
this dude is the guy and we're
introducing them second like how do you
how do you even ask another player to go
after that like that's a very
interesting so I found out a tweet about
that then bang they responded they said
do you think you can do better I like
absolutely let's do this I am by the way
they were so hospitable so nice the fact
that they gave me that opportunity is
just ridiculously nice from the palmares
organization but I still had to
introduce I on second and that was so
what so you couldn't reconfigure the
order of the manner in which you you
wanted like a theme when I walked in
there for rehearsal but they wanted to
get it there was a lot of people by the
way in that pelicans organization who
were not sold on be doing
[Applause]
the social-media guy was the guy
basically pushing for this I think yes
Alex he's a good dude he was pushing
hard for it so they wanted me to do a
rehearsal and they hand me the note you
know the dalish the order the rule the
number everything and I see Zion ii on
there and I'm like yes I'm not
introduced in a second right they're
like um yeah you kind of have to with
the way our videos are set up and
everything I'm like well that's why I'm
here though because they're like yeah
you have to we don't wanna put too much
on him he's 19 your day like made me
feel bad about it and I was like okay
hey I'll do whatever the hell you want
me to do just let me go ahead and go it
out here and yell a little bit don't go
second but we did have quite a
give-and-take about it and I lost the
battle I lost the bet yeah okay so who
did go after Zion that was the whole
point of you going down there was to do
him last because that's your point is
that he's I on Williamson you got he's
the last one to go right come on
so Derrick Favors yeah favors weren't
third directly after Zion hmm and I
completely agree no I didn't know him
that well so it wasn't it wasn't my best
intro but then Lonzo ball was fourth
right
I loved your intro for him your intro
for him was laugh out loud hilarious I
would have want Wando ball first right
then hit a couple in the middle drew
holiday then Zion Williamson right but
the team was so cool about it and I was
very lucky to be a part of it but boy
the internet enjoyed it and I didn't
burn any bridges good news certainly
since as you're reporting here on the
Rich Eisen show you are not the
consensus choice of the pelicans see I
told Pat when we were when I was there
and he's doing this I'm like you've got
a like how are you gonna do it with Zion
are you gonna drag out desire nor the
Williams and like no it's got to be Zion
and let that thing go like it was ready
to rumble I would have never done that I
would I would have gone yeah I would
have gone heavy on the Williamson mm-hmm
instead of the xylan and really he's a
guy that likes Tiger when a mathlete Ron
yeah yeah only need one name so what you
said was very accurate I have to go hard
on that first that's the one that's a
great name it's next level you know I
just got to be honest with you I thought
it was next level suggestion for you but
that was so funny as you are sir hey man
I love doing your show love seeing your
operation it's it's first-rate man
it's first-rate you and everybody there
should be very very very happy and proud
of what you're building over there in
Indianapolis pal well we appreciate that
you know we got a lot of guys over here
that work hard
hey most of these guys quit their jobs
whenever I quit mine as well so I mean
we've invested a lot we're lucky to do
it we enjoy the hell out of it and I am
so happy for you and your boys over
there and your group over there next
time to make this transition to the
youtubes you're gonna start owning it
man you're gonna do very well and I
thought them to watch you all right
Patrick you take care of yourself yes I
would say though none of my guys would
get the birth place of the guests wrong
because if you could guess where I'm
born I mean whatever you want name it no
nobody he's not even but he would say he
would he would say he would have it
researched properly if it was his job
for the best I think he is I think he is
appropriately busting your stones right
now wow this is an appropriate bus
though I'm there I'm just saying my guys
would be running Sprint's out on the
basketball court if that was to happen
you know Bob Knight type up Bob well I
mean it is Indiana right I mean you're
on the state of Indiana so I appreciate
you guys having me all right back at
your pad you're the best we'll chat soon
that's up you got it that's Pat McAfee
his show live every single day week day
ten at noon Eastern Time and check out
his pod